hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
this is a fairly infrequent but highly
enjoyable podcast that myself and deaf
do on Watchmen on Alan Moore and Dave
Gibbons remarkable graphic novel it's
truly a quick sound in a certain sense
when when you read the eyes and if you
feel the same way deaf like the more I
read it the more I love it I don't
really like it to be on its old for you
it's to us I like the ones where you
know the new one where it's like the
fight in everyone and it's got little
man with the mime ha ha it's got black
Rorschach game you know I'm one of them
Star Wars fans who hates the original
trilogy especially Empire Strikes Back
because it's the most boringest one I'm
one of them you are a rogue one I am I'm
sort of a new hope when you think about
it I'm sort of The Return of the Jedi
I'm sort of the attack of the clones I'm
a Ren's Roy activist and it's but get
back to Watchmen as a whole I mean I
mean exploring it deaf it's we're deep
now this is episode 6 we've talked about
this for probably like five six hours
probably longer than any director's cut
of any film you know it's been it's been
a deep conversation I mean it's still so
long to go yes that's right Tom and and
I know I say this every single episode
but actually think this issue was the
best one of the series so far because
it's focused isn't it there's no
deviations it's like issue for the dr.
Manhattan issue it's a pure origin it's
also intelligently because you know we
know from comics normally this sort of
issue in a run the secret origin of Iron
Man or some [ __ ] like that you know
they'll always kind of have that Stan
Lee archetype there but here it's a
psychoanalyst kind of analyzing this
psychopath that we've been familiar with
for five issues for how long in this
world and we're seeing him broken down
into Sarah
it's the perfect way to tell an origin
story yeah it's absolutely brilliant and
it's got none of that black freighter
[ __ ] in no don't like it off but it's
got no filler in it you know there's
nothing there there's no side character
who's like a news vendor you know I mean
he's in Italy for a panel or something
but yeah yeah but it's you know get rid
of them yeah skip that page I hate this
book I skip the whole issue so skip the
podcast if you want so I go man I want
to talk about this issue is it is crazy
as you say and you know this is the
abyss gazes also is the name of the
issue and we'll start with the the
covered death which you know basically
it's a Rorschach test for a viewer is
Nate showing you an image and it's just
saying what do you make of this yeah and
I like how it's the first panel as well
played it's also the second panel you
know what I'm saying
lazy for the fine more oh yeah but yeah
it's it's just you know it lets you know
straight away exactly what the issues
about and it's sort of what do you take
from this yeah yeah and it does sort of
look like a dog with its head split oh
when I must say even before Rorschach
mention it I was like that's a bloody
dog with its head split open no you are
right and I mean looking at it though as
well on the cover I don't know if as I
say we're very deep into this deaf and
I'm looking for things on there is it
kind of like a blood splatter the red
light kindly yeah and it's got a nice
yellow tinge to the background and it's
got you know flashes of red on it so
it's once again carrying the motif of
like this smiley face yeah
with the the like little red splashes on
it and the black face so the Scarlet
like blood I'm a genius for just
noticing that now it's you know you know
in some sort of odd way even though it's
his face
if Rorschach was like a typical
superhero like a Batman Superman with
the insignia on his chest it probably
would be this cover yeah definitely yeah
it's just a nice impactful cover really
just sums up
like Rorschach it's probably the best
one we've ever had I'm trying to think
what the dr. Manhattan issue cover was
like if only I had some way of looking
at that dr. Manhattan cover straightaway
oh wait I do of Timmy had right so yeah
the dr. Manhattan cover was the old
photograph love that cover him in Janey
Slater
so yeah it's sort of a nice callback to
like this is gonna be the origin story
of Rorschach in the same way that that
was the origin story of old doc what's
up doc they used to say in it when he
goes about up is a relative theorem or
something in Trent it has no intrinsic
value classic you know there's lots of
sort of dual parallels in this like the
inkblot between Malcolm the therapist
and Rorschach you know both becoming
yeah you know Malcolm Orso being
indoctrinated as a doctor into this this
is a lot of references then to issue one
both the weight zooms out is similar to
the you know the smile button at the
start of issue one or you know when when
when Dan is telling the joke we still
expect her on the rooftop that ends the
issue but also the inner monologue you
know we learn that with Rorschach sports
what we hear for his diary now it's
quite cool we have the notes of the
therapist who sort of charting these
sessions as we read yeah and it
completely introduces a new character
hmm and it's exactly from his
perspective he so the the layman and I
don't believe that superheroes at this
point in comics had been deconstructed
psychologically and this is sort of the
first time that it ever happens and it
shows you that in order to like have
this vigilante lifestyle you'd probably
have to be a psychopath yeah or a
sociopath and so yeah it's really fresh
take on things like that no point did
anyone ever sort of question like what
in the person's past would make them do
these horrific deeds mmm yeah and yeah
it's it's sort of the psychiatrist
himself throughout the arc and trust
issue goes on and hawk himself he sort
of
he starts off he seems to want Fame more
than anything and it doesn't really care
that much about Rorschach and he seems
to just want to probably write a book
about it and but throughout the issue he
slowly gets broken down and you know he
might even become Rorschach
one day in Doomsday Clock yeah my baby
yeah it was only three black characters
in this universe
yeah Warner was incinerated so it's but
I guess the first issue that we get a
black character in as a focus we also
get the N bomb dropped a couple of times
yeah nice one more when we do the
Quentin Tarantino of comics you could
kind of tell from that off really that
he's going to change because you know we
have to title the abyss gazes also this
Nietzsche idea of you know if you saw
plain dirt you get dirty essentially you
know you yeah you know you corrupt and
you know he's looking at him in the
fifth panel you know he doesn't blink
back you know so it's just kind of his
echo of himself and yeah the artwork is
fantastic and also the way more garishly
delivers his credentials you know he's
peer-reviewed they tell me I'm very good
with people
you know who tells him that he's very
good people what people you know he's
not really been tested like yeah yeah
it's probably just sat at home like
analyzed it's in 12 year olds and stuff
who've been bullied at school or
something I don't want to slug your off
if you 12 been your own bullied at
school but yeah he's probably like one
of them he's never really had a case
that's this mental and it's this issue
has a really very good dark humor to it
like I think more or in sex cells and is
sort of you know that there's a comedic
side to everything in Gibbons also like
is a master of that so like the whole
not blinking and just staring back at
each other and there's lots of panels
where Rorschach sort of expressionless
and it just makes you like have a little
smirk to yourself I'll talk about one of
the panel's later on but there's a
hilarious moment that really shouldn't
be that funny right
and something that's quite depressing is
the visage of the dog that Rorschach
sees in the inkblot of its you know head
cut into the brain visible the yellow
braid it's yeah quite startling
oh yeah hundred percent and it's it's
definitely one of the up to this point
it probably is the goriest image in this
comic your Pam it's just like it's
completely out the blue and yeah it's a
bit messed up yeah yeah and it's sort of
intriguing as well it's like why is this
guy like I know I know all of us that's
that's what we see when we close our
eyes is just a dog with its head split
open but you know why do you see that
Tom when you close your eyes was that I
don't know that's what we're gonna find
out on this issue but you know it's it's
just like normal things that I myself
see so it's nice to see one of my
favorite characters also seeing the same
thing and one of the things we do see a
lot in watch one of these Y panels you
know often they're all these annoying
panel pages but as we turn onto page two
with the title we get something that's
normally reserved a great action you
know moments of revelation here and it's
no different then to see it at this
table I mean this is such a pivotal
moment you know to us learning about
Rorschach into you know the therapist
learning by himself yeah it's just like
in a staring at each other
just two people trying to understand the
other the complete polar opposites and
it's just like it's a it's a nice
juxtaposition yeah that's the word of
the podcast J barking yeah yeah make
sure you comment juxtaposition in the
comments below you and will read out
your comment next week yeah yeah on the
podcast but just right juxtaposition i
its bookended boy inkblot tests that are
given to wall check that being his
childhood flashback to his mother and if
you just if you didn't know anything
about watchmen and you just read this
you know this quite horrific tale of
this kid coming in and they sort of
mother gets no money and she gets abused
etc you know it's just a really i don't
know it's very affecting tale to read
actually I think it's rendered so well
the emotion so rich
yeah and what I love about it is rush
like Kovacs which is war shocks
alter-ego he throughout the issue he's
completely expressionless and pretty
much which completely plays into the
duality of his alter-ego like
Rorschach's mask is nothing but
expressions it's constantly changing
it's constantly moving and you know the
circuit moves in certain ways when he's
surprised when he gets angry the the
bubbles kind of scrunched together and
there's a lot of expression constantly
going on in that mask when he takes it
off he's just like he's not there he
just yeah seems like he's a shell of a
person and it just plays off it's so
well liked it's the it's the dual side
of your personality that we all have we
all have this personality that we show
to the world and then there's another
like shadow side of us that it's come
the complete opposite and it's great
just to see how you know juxtaposing
Rorschach is in his personalities yeah
on the third page where you you pretty
much see his expression I'd say maybe
four or five times see the back of his
head a little bit as he walks in on his
mother
it does just have the same look it's
just it's just affixed on his face you
know there's no age and he just started
horror and I mean this is a very very
nice very very on the nose but
nonetheless brilliant the the inkblot
becoming the mother with the Jon the
silhouettes yeah it's quite strange that
he's so messed up when he had such a
normal childhood
right what do you mean it isn't what
happens normally every I did get
straight like [ __ ] so it basically walks
in on his parent well not his parents
but his mom you know I get enough of
this crap at home the guy says you know
just like oh the Rorschach gets called a
[ __ ]
his mother screams she should have had
the abortion you know it's sort of goes
against the typical superhero motif
where the child had amazing parents and
then they became often like Clark Kent's
parents are said to be the best people
in the world
our brew farm folk yet that raised him
right good stock
Bruce Wayne's parents you know lovely
people theater lovers billionaires yet
they took one of them's a doctor Leah
that probably did loads for Cherry
gunned down in an alley they were up
with the perfect parents Uncle Ben you
know he made wonderful rice you made it
that he made that amazing rice for all
the time for Peter Uncle Ben's rice if
he didn't cut chocolates yeah and it sir
and it's kinda gets that where Rorschach
parents were absolute just horrendous to
him yeah there's some there's a to panel
motif that I just have to give praise to
Gibbons for at the top of page four
where the the mother the cuss you know
the mother watch the customer leaves the
back of his legs going out the door
she's gripping the five dollars and then
she turns to him enraged it's like she
sort of sees the consequence of what
happens and just sort of he's fear on
young Rorschach's face you know really
upsetting you know the movie he's
brilliant and it's great you said color
as well because everything just goes
black red and yellow and when she gets
angry and it's such a and intense
feeling of rage and she just beats the
crap out of them and then once again it
goes back to the black and yellow
silhouette on the wall that merges into
the Rorschach test so it's a it's a nice
sort of them turn around and to me
Rorschach is a psychopath with a hero
complex um he's a bit like Batman it
could have went either to the dark side
but instead he took this horrendous
these horrendous things that happened in
his life and channeled them and good
it's I mean the way Rorschach acts it's
still sociopathic and it harms people
but Rorschach can justify it as he's
hurting villains and to him he's not
hurting people he's hurting criminals
and you know it's great when he goes
back to you you were taken back to the
prison and he's realized like how
horrific of a situation that
he's now in when he's heading to the
cell yeah he's in a prison where he put
most of the inmates in but he's still
completely unflinching there's
absolutely no fear there and then he
sort of when he sits down he breaks as
he remembers it all but it's not like a
an upsetting break it's sort of like
it's just eyebrows point down and anger
and he just gets really angry as he like
remembers his childhood and yeah just
it's just brilliantly like it's such a
well done characterization with very
little very little expression there but
you completely understand from his
perspective exactly why he hates the
world and acts the way that he does yeah
yeah the naiveness naivete I should say
of the therapist you know saying you
think's is hope
yeah he's completely misunderstood in
some sort of you know barbaric way there
and broad shock remains who he is one of
the goat scenarios in drama in fiction
is the hated criminal going to prison
and everyone wanting to kill him I'm
thinking specifically about I don't even
seen the wire but when Omar goes to
prison he's a brilliant sequence really
as ever wants to kill this drug dealer
who stole them from everyone who's in
yeah because of him and yeah this is
what we get here and we get that you
know more it has such a superior voice
for horror violence you know you've got
a mother she's dead you've got kids
they're dead as sister dead and just all
I think overlapping is also stuff blocks
out stuff but you can kind of paint the
blanks for how terrible this is yeah and
just seeing Rorschach as a kid like
attacking criminals he's always been
this like mental over-the-top fighter he
kind of guy like we was he in the bar
when he was breaking that guy's fingers
during an interrogation here he grabs a
bully cigarette out of his mouth stabs
it in his eye jumps on another one bites
his cheek off yeah and it's just like
this you can see this you lucky that
this guy is a hero
yeah because otherwise it'd be a [ __ ]
mental patient
mmm-hmm ya know just the the comparisons
on 6 & 7 of the clouded you know clouds
here and everything overlapping and I
don't know if you felt this as well baby
just a coincidence when he's doing you
know the sister that dead exedra that
you see you've got a dog it's and I
don't know if that's like an ironic
consideration of later on
yeah probably is it sort of shows how
different you know his childhood was no
nobody cared who he was till he put on
the mask I'm saying
is it a point Apple initially he's
putting on voice what he's smashed on
his face I don't know he's just little
fruit yeah it looks like a custard pie
obviously it kind of looks like a yeah
it looks at the block but maybe I'd like
s CBeebies presenter or so ain't gotta
know yeah good and bring it up Dave
Benson Phillips yeah as you say plucks
the cigarette out of the torn his mouth
Dobbs Italy very small huh you know yeah
seeing this from Rorschach when he gets
captured you know using the fire and he
knows kind of how to make decisions
quickly and tail out but him gripping
the skin and pulling it so far and
pulling the mouth as well apart of his
hands he's a [ __ ] they say like a Mad
Dog and yeah yeah he saw it as a bit of
a mad dog because murder at the door
look anyway hey yeah he's just going
mental isn't he like he finally snaps
and he just realizes he doesn't have to
take this [ __ ] from people he's
completely above them he'll do whatever
it takes whereas they're just calling
him names and like shoving through fruit
in his face that they are basically they
sum up society that's the level that
they will go to in their wickedness
Rorschach's above society and it's just
a whole different level of craziness
like they'll shove fruit in your face
he'll do something above that rip the
cigarette out your mouth
yes stab it in your eye and then bite
off your face yeah it just shows that
he's above as wicked as you think you
are new thing who I'm being a bit of a
badass yeah
now Rorschach's like next level I'm
gonna kill you and you know we're
learning about this concurrently both
through Rorschach flashing back to
Kovacs and also Malcom making his notes
and you know Malcolm is sort of
chronicling how you know when he grew to
a bright unusually bright child one of
the things that I like here is the
similarity in color between what's
wife's wearing and then they both have
this kind of obviously yellow that kind
of points to a comparison yeah and it's
weird how like well I don't mean it's
weird but it's nice that they sort of
show in this issue what a happy home
life looks like mm-hm and it's just a
nice sort of relaxing thing for him you
see that he's not went through anything
that Rorschach has um and you know he's
got a nice happy marriage at the
beginning here and everything seems fine
but he gets slowly sucked into the abyss
and we see all gonna [ __ ] you know he is
kind of just talking about the Chronicle
here what goes on as well he says he's
too fat and contented for anything to
ruin his disposition as well openness
unfortunately shadows play out here
something I never noticed death and I
was reading a little article about this
issue of just kind of cool things you
might have missed and I you but gotta
admit I'd nuts in it still this morning
the bottom of page eight as you know the
influence is starting to seep into the
therapist you know he started to believe
to a certain extent become enamored um
we see his pen and ink yeah so you know
the ink blot it's slowly starting to
seep into his life yeah brilliant more
well Daisy who's that who's that hello
to me I'm back again more more and more
how do you like it pull my finger hi mo
so we're just seeing the the ink blot
test your stink blot ha ha so we I tell
them anyway guys I'll see you next week
tear out that was sullen mode his
puffing again explain one of his their
issues yeah so I'm glad that you said
something intelligent and I followed it
up with that because it sort of shows
the juxtaposition and duality of
personalities in between us or Alberta
you Tom we see you know insight is given
to characters not only through history
and text but just through image we see
in the early panels of this page eight
ad on a mug so obviously we think it's
dad you do actually see the mug as dad
when you first see the ink lot which is
interesting it pulls out on the panel
panel so they see it doesn't have kids
that appear in this comic no no that's
all we get all we get is the mug but I
mean it's Watchmen so you can imagine
and yeah I mean they're quite old
they're clearly in love they're probably
got you know kids why not yeah and as
they walk off to the bedroom we see
their shadows on the wall once again
it's this repetition of the the the
lovers shadows on on walls yeah yeah
similar to Hiroshima
you know it's counting down at this bomb
that's gonna go off yeah yeah
singing it's similar to the Ganga diner
which has a kind of oddly yeah magical
logo as well you know Watchmen is
crystalline in structure
I love the paneling on page nine
especially which is essentially made up
of just one on you know portraits of the
characters reacting to what's going on
and if you just take them on face value
you can see what's dominating are the
four Kovacs portraits at the right panel
for them and there's just two of
Malcolm's startled you know by the
attack these haven't read your yeah well
in the first meeting Rorschach just told
them what he wanted to hear basically
was like when he was looking at the ink
blot test he was saying I see
butterflies in summer and McDonald's and
you know just great things I'd like to
just take this moment to say that this
week's episode of the podcast is
sponsored by McDonald's the healthy way
to start your day I'm loving it
anyway so this is where he kind of
breaks it to him I don't like you you
know you're fat wealthy you think you
understand pain I'll tell you something
doctor
I'll tell you about Rorschach and then
he goes off into this this crazy sort of
back story where we once again see
Rorschach working with female clothing
and he's got a grim shocked expression
on his face obviously you know it its
heralding back to him seeing bras
hanging up at his mom's house and it's
very psychologically damaging to him um
Rorschach to me is just it is a sexual a
one-pot when he says he's handling
female clothing it's bearable but
unpleasant and he sort of got no
personality Rorschach like and we do see
it in his when he's Walter Kovacs he's
shy and he just has no personality like
other than a mental person like I don't
think as a child we even see him speak
um right oh yeah you see he says like
I'm on the way to the shop for my mom
but yeah not much no I mean let us see
it yeah so let me talk a little um he
just sort of reacts to things and then
he develops this persona that is sort of
the perfect version of himself and it's
I watched this documentary on rap stars
once right I can't believe I said rap
stars and nachos rappers and and it was
sort of talked about how rappers create
an amplified lifestyle and Rorschach
does it but he doesn't as a hero and
then he sort of starts to become this
hero and finally he feels like he means
something and he's attracted to the
fabric which he makes into a mask and
there's no gray areas in the mask which
he loves which of course like it's it's
his persona upset it about 700 times on
the podcast so far and where he loves
that there's just black and why there's
no in between him and it just sums him
up purse perfectly interesting the dr.
Manhattan effectively began Rorschach
and through kind of creating this you
know sort of odd two layered latex yeah
and it's nice that like dr. Manhattan's
sort of inspire
superheroes as well in comics a lot of
the time when they start a new universe
or on a TV show they'll start with one
character who has superpowers and then
more and more people develop them and
they'll sort of comment ow this only
happened because you've got super powers
like everyone had to up their game and
escalate and they talked about it at the
end of the Dark Knight no Batman Begins
sorry where because Batman has put on a
mask and is now fighting criminals
criminals are gonna have to find another
way to fight back so they start putting
on masks and I believe they actually
mentioned that in Watchmen as well and
so Batman causes the Joker and it's nice
that there's this cause and effect of
once the first Superman appears others
start to and in two years it takes
apparently cuts the fabric into the mask
into how he wants it but it takes a
little while an actual woman who ordered
the dress
kitty Genovese is right tortured in
front of the public and this is the
first sort of catalyst into crime
fighting for Walter right yeah it sort
breaks him and I think it's more the
people just watching mm-hmm
that does it for him he realizes that
people as a whole are terrible and just
want to sit back and watch things happen
is that is that what watchman's about
it's at the title yeah it is yeah just
stand back watching everything instead
of making a difference and I think
that's what makes shocks snap and
realize he doesn't want to be part of
society anymore and you know
Malcolm's scrambles for an answer to
this and I think he comes up with one
quite good consume mainly not
considering the Watchmen well because it
is crime riddled but he says you know
the whole thing is not proof that the
mankind is rotten you've been
conditioned of a negative world through
that are good people too and you know he
kind of makes an appeal to himself but I
guess you can you can still sympathize
with Rorschach to a certain saying I
think all makes it plain and clear how
this person would happen quite um
yeah and I do actually think this is one
of the most introspective pages for a
reader because Rorschach he says you you
think you're good people like that
everyone probably thinks they're a good
person and this was sort of when I first
read this it was sort of the panel where
I in respectively questioned myself like
am ia good person right and it's it's
sort of it is gazing into this abyss and
to me the comic sort of leaps out at you
at this point it makes you question
yourself and which is absolutely like
all great works make you do that they
don't make you look at them they make
you look at yourself and Watchmen does
that here and you know I guess similarly
as well and when we see Walter as a
child we see a sequence of horrified
faces and now when we see him actually
focused engaging with what happened
there we see a series of horrified faces
you know yes we do see Malcolm
continuing in this way as he leaves and
I love the look of Walter Rorschach when
he's getting up off the table and sort
of very dyed his face is so black isn't
it as he says you know your your basic
interviewing me in the same way you'd
interview John Lennon's killer you know
it's kind of a notorious case yeah and
it's sort of the reason that he starts
to overshadow everything where is in in
the past and if you use very much on his
level and and now he's sort of towering
above him telling him like you're
pathetic I hate you you know the pill
popping continues for Malcolm that we
see throughout yeah it's nice that
Rorschach sort of went from being
horrified about everything - now
horrifying people yeah yeah we really
having an effect on someone who I know
Malcolm slightly closeted but he's
clearly an accomplished therapist
he's probably encountered a lot of cases
and even for him this is Freud email
yeah though I probably oughta like
divorce a women you know I mean sure
self entertaining yeah yeah I don't want
to slug the lad
therapy off you know I mean but I don't
think he's come out for this it's
interesting on page 12 we tried argue
he's one of the most iconic moments in
Watchmen I think most people remember
this moment you know it's it's just a
absolutely you know galling moment
really but interesting nonetheless
he's Rorschach in the queue for lunch
being friend in quite an inventive way
by this prison thug calling his knife
his pocketbook it's not just took quite
a few famous names over the years yeah
it's just like in Rorschach and he knows
what's gonna happen
he's just so preparing himself I think
the film expertly like captures this
moment sure and it definitely is like
one of the scenes that stick in your
head from the film um and it's just once
again shows like this guy was gonna
knife Rorschach and once again shows
that Rorschach no man I like how bad you
think it's gonna be what you're gonna do
to him
he's just gonna do something so much
worse that it completely like like
Rorschach probably could have taken
being knifed this guy he's not gonna
recover from getting boiling up cooking
oil thrown in his face he's above prison
level aggression like he's like true
psycho aggression yeah it's just
absolutely mental the guy is a complete
psychopath you've gotta love him he's a
loveable psychopath his name
he's lucky as a psychopath he's lucky
where he is on the queue because if you
look at him the boiling is in front of
him so he can grab it if he was ever on
and he just froze sprouts at him he
wouldn't work yeah but you probably knew
something like this was gonna happen so
he's sort of planned out bit I mean he
seems like the guy he would always have
a plan um I walk like if he got to this
sprout he'd probably like stab the guy
with his own knife and then stuff
sprouts down his throat till he choked
or something you know I mean he'd always
find some I hey we wouldn't walk past
that line thinking I'll throw one of
these foods into his face like
Rorschach would like we would find a
weapon out of anything like you can see
along just that there's some like knives
and forks yeah just along from the she
wrote so you know he would have always
found something yeah he would have found
some way Buddhist but he wouldn't have
stuck there like knife in your stomach
you know I mean you just stuck the fork
in your balls oh you know what I mean
that's what Rorschach would do I'm sort
of like Rorschach now I think about it
bit of a legend I mean it's fair to say
what Rorschach does has destroyed this
man for life yeah well it dies I think
there's knee or he doesn't
yeah I think when the prison riot
happens late is because he dies and that
sort of kicks off the riot and they know
it's gonna happen because it the guys in
critical condition like pink yellow skin
like stalking yeah in the film as well I
can just see like in my head the guy's
face melting um yeah and it's just a
terrific thing yeah it's yeah it's
unbelievable
I loved that panel at the bottom the
look of everyone from the police guard
with the baton ready to this horizontal
this is the the dark comedy bit that I
was gonna talk about earlier it's just
like oh expression the way Dave Gibbons
draws like the faces of like yeah yeah
just all the flights the flecks of food
it's gonna hang out and yeah it's it's
brilliant it's absolutely brilliant I
love it and you see the knife as well
suspended in midair kind of you know oh
man absolutely insane we'd cut as well
there's a lot of rhyming in this book
you know scenes go into scene so we have
the the splashing bubbling of skin into
the you know pop wing of a coffee pot
yeah let's
yeah just nicely in it wine so scenes
together it doesn't feel too daunting or
jarring it just really was completely
planned this out and I will say every
single episode but the level of
complexity that comes across so
simplistic is up
breathtaking and and it doesn't a
brilliant job once again yeah yeah it's
it's wonderful we hear you'd the whole
I'm not locked up in here with you
you're locked up in here with me yeah
racism will see that in the film don't
we I think we see him say that yeah he
say so after he throws the the fat on
the guy's face but it's just like one of
those lines that it's completely
brilliant you know none of you
understand I'm not locked in here with
you you're locked in here with me which
was actually the line from my yearbook
ham under my face
so that was my quote do you see really
do you see in panel for a kind of ink
block burnt on the coffee-room yeah I
thought I saw someone said outline of
like good you know so oh it's a dream
right look at the coffee fighting his
house what's up it's vital air yeah just
take a moment to remind listeners of
this podcast is sponsored by Adrian
Veidt na Stiles yeah you smell like [ __ ]
but smell like how I used to smell come
on dust I'll cheer by nostalgia he's got
cancer you should care about him now
yeah he's gonna blow up your city by his
stuff I'm a marionette I'm gonna chat
yeah can't wait to see how that plays
off in doomsday yeah yeah baby brilliant
shout out doomsday we have received some
emails for that so we're gonna read
those out in the doomsday we are gonna
read that email us at the end of this
show as well I should say include we've
got some good ones so yeah we see
something that is classic more you know
he's an afraid to get involved in issues
of intimacy and you know build towards
that and I think even though you know
what is this a 20 30 page comic or
something you know very brief really the
relationship between Malcolm and his
wife Gloria is compelling and you know
quite sexual as well yeah she seems like
a bit of a frisky
but he's like just let us do my world
case yeah yeah she's probably one of
them Desperate Housewives you know I
mean just sits in the house all day cuz
a husband's got a cushy job and then
she'll be cheating next week she'll be
cheating now Cena yet again you know
it's not Rorschach's past but it's his
current present that horrifies wall
Malcolm and you know we see him in the
middle here I love the sort of diffuse
gray and green and his bowtie and
wrapped around his neck yeah pills more
coffee more reading and he acknowledges
that what Rorschach had said applies to
him as well you locked up in here with
me he said he's right absolutely right
yeah and it's great slowly starting to
come to the realization that Rorschach
is correct and everything in the view of
the world that he's had is wrong and
it's just completely breaking him and
it's nice that we're slowly getting up
to speed for present day with Rorschach
as he's filling in his backstory and we
started off when he was a child and now
we're sort of coming into when he's
developed this persona of Rorschach yeah
he's out being a vigilante yeah when we
met him essentially you know he gets to
that stage and we learned that he was
quite interestingly even with the mask
on not necessarily Rorschach yet he was
a slightly softer form and slightly more
antiquated really slightly more Batman
ass guy supposed to a certain extent
lately and Liv leaving insignias behind
and playing by the rules mostly and I
like how he sort of addresses Rorschach
as something that you can only become
when you're truly broken I say is that
he wasn't Rorschach at this point he was
just Kovacs pretending to be Rorschach
and and it's sort of you know it talks
about how he thinks he's at this level
but he realizes that he's not at all
he's not had to encounter something
that's gonna transform him into this
absolute monster of a man and and it
really speaks volumes to the psychology
of alter ego and how Rorschach is like
the dark thing that lives within you
that will burst free I you might think
you're evil you might think you're like
as bad as you can be but there's going
to be something that will happen that
will bring out the worst in you and
that's when you will become your true
self and that is rorschach the wrong you
know the spirits of happiness throughout
this like I do like the panel of seeing
him and night out just sort of shaking
hands and you know enjoying this more
slightly more innocent period we get the
therapist talking about his criminal
record and how Rorschach seems to really
be right in saying that he changed
because you can see that from what was
recorded against him you know he's
turned towards harder more horrific
crimes and it just makes you realize yet
again through more what superheroes have
really been like like can you imagine
Joker's criminal record you know yeah
well I'm sure like someone did a count
of it and it was over like killing over
ten thousand people like God but he
always gets off with it cuz he's insane
yeah I mean Rorschach recounts more and
more here we see them go against what
reminds me yet again about 1960s Batman
like I love seeing the guys at the docks
have like broken bottles banners it's
always at the dark just tied to like a
lamppost or something yeah and we see
yet again this meeting that we see a
million times that I love the meeting we
are hearing sing comedian now I guess in
a certain little microcosm taste of what
Russia will become I either fire they
engulf the house we see the fire engulf
the map here and captain metropolis
tried his best to stop it but it's
already done yeah and something very
subtle that Dave Gibbons does with the
Rorschach mask is he draws the inkblot
like patches large and round which sort
of it's not the Disneyfication of
characters where they all have like wide
eyes big massive eyes that make them
look more innocent and similar this
Rorschach looks more innocent because
his mask is like the blacks on it are a
lot bigger a lot rounder a lot wider so
seems like they're more less like
skeptical of the world mm-hmm and as we
go on we sort of see the the ink blots
tighten up and get closer together as he
gets angrier and they become sort of
deformed they're no longer perfect
circle's they're a big like weird
spirally twists and stuff it's a really
nice little subtle touch yeah definitely
it's definitely something to keep an eye
on as if all these panels for some
reason silk spectres laughing uh was she
laughing at this point I don't remember
that maybe it's just the way that
Rorschach views of women sure he sort of
remembers it like like to him all women
are like aging laughing [ __ ] breath
you know I mean yeah I'm sure he says
something along those lines as well and
so he probably just remembers that I hmm
yeah we see the clock there as well we
see on the next panel because we never
see who watches to watch them fully as a
text and the whole thing and I quite
like that this one is interrupted
because because share the guy trying to
do it yeah it's great and I've just I
take this opportunity to remind people
that this episode is sponsored by the
watching The Watchmen podcast subscribe
you know sometimes it's lame in sort of
like I don't know dramas and stuff when
people read stuff on newspapers but I do
like it in Watchmen I do like seeing
that it means we see badges not masks
and disposed sign and you know talk of
the Keene Act being passed so we are
very much you know in the present during
these recollections and you know it goes
deeper I like how we get a little bit
and then there's another one and then we
get a little bit so you know we get to
see no further troubles you know from
Malcolm in various guises inferring away
and of a pill packet of go pain him
looking like a corpse in his bed he
looks looks like just go through some
Tara that's his wife isn't it it's brief
yeah I always thought with him and but
when I look over a shoulder I think it's
the wife staring and you've got the nice
little Doomsday Clock you know it's
their alarm clock just sat on the side
of the bed nice little touch
mm-hmm and we have character progression
you know in a beautiful form we have
Rorschach admitting what he initially
saw here which is conjured back up which
F just figures really nice story doesn't
sound like much that a character thinks
of something early and remembers it and
recounts it but it's just quite a nice
thing in comics have the process of for
displayed quite intricately and him
coming back with the dog split head and
it's leading into this sequence which
leads to you know ultimately the birth
of Rorschach one of the most celebrated
sequences right death a hundred percent
absolutely brilliant it's you know he
goes into that house one man and comes
out another like you can even see on his
mask the big wide circles and they sort
of get twisted the further he goes into
the house and it's just absolutely
brilliant
watching him it's again that's the
dressmaker's it's an abandoned
dressmaker which it's interesting that
more has kind of chose a dressmaker to
be the the place where Rorschach was
born once and then reborn right and I in
in initially the dressmaker's was a
really nice place and it's sort of
dilapidated now and rundown and this is
what happens to Rorschach's personality
as well you know yeah sort of
disembodied limbs and torsos of women
yeah yeah yeah I didn't really consider
that it was both those dressing places
that's that's very true yet even just
like the sewing machine on the floor and
just so many details it's just beautiful
and wordless as well which Watchmen
isn't afraid to do to have these page or
two pages where nothing is said we just
showed so much yeah and you can tell
exactly the thought process that's going
through Rorschach's head as he puts two
and two together and as a reader you do
the same thing and then the last panel
on page 20 where he realizes that the
dogs of eating this head the poll panel
just goes read and you can tell he's
just angry he picks up a meat cleaver
goes out and you see how the dog got its
head
open yes yeah and he becomes almost
movie you know Jason asked you know what
I mean like I sort of just man killer
yeah like a mad killer or a mask and
yeah it's just great and the gore
becomes next level I this is definitely
the goriest Watchmen issue and like when
you see the dog flung through the window
yeah and it's just next-level so just
the wooden board where the child has
been carved on like ah yeah it's just
great um and you see this guy return
home psyches anyone got a bark for daddy
yeah I'm a called like Barney and Fred
yeah oh my god nice and he's not a bad
guy
no one who likes the Flintstones can be
that bad but he just yeah his name is
Gerald Bryce you know he was out
drinking and he returns so Rorschach as
basically what it's saying has killed
these dogs at what seems like kind of
dusk maybe but not necessarily night and
then just yeah hated you know knowing he
will come back yeah get a little bit of
time with his guys he enters and he sees
reflection and again just beautifully
told oh yeah absolutely brilliant it
just scares the [ __ ] out of his guy like
and you sort of what does a really good
job of sort of making you feel sorry for
this criminal coming home even though
he's cut the kid even though he's fed it
to his dogs you sort of feel like a bit
sorry for him and I know you probably
talked him well but reading at like in
the movie I didn't when I watched it
before eating it like this I do a bit
and it sort of shows that Rorschach at
this point has just elevated above
society is now above the law he's
completely detached from it he feels no
he feels nothing for this guy he just
wants to just get rid of him
you know stamp him out yeah in the same
way put a dog down he's putting down
this man
yeah yeah and you know we spend a lot of
time in the actual complex itself so
architectural you get to know where you
are and the fact that it's thrown out of
the central window and then through the
front door as well is just you know
again it's like a horror movie villain
you don't mean someone just chucking
corpses in to scare you yeah and it sort
of becomes like a saw villain as well
yeah yeah he like ties him to the boiler
douses the place in gasoline gives him a
saw and says like you'll not have enough
time to saw through the handcuffs you
know you give to my local wink you know
I mean like you know you know work I
want to play a game yeah yeah I want you
to cut off your hand you like to cut
things now you know I mean so the light
from soul would be like you like to good
things don't you
you you love bit of cutting well I'm
good to me you cut your losses I want to
play a game and then he's like wheel out
on his little bike there's little
tricycle yeah girl cute rising real oh
yeah and this doll listen Mad Max write
em the original Mad Max movie I'm sure
has something similar this um yeah
so it clearly is a great moment yeah
yeah I mean at least he gives him a
choice gives him a slight choice but I
mean he drops the match instantly after
littering kerosene everywhere you know
and we get some some good old-fashioned
diary literature from Rorschach imagine
limbless felt torsos inside breasts
blackening bellies smoldering bursting
into flame one by one watched for an
hour and enough I'd come to him looking
at Malcolm nobody got out yeah I know
you know I don't know why like it it's
such a poetic thing to stand back and
just look at a fire burn yo yeah um and
it's good to me this has got so much
atmosphere to it like he's just watching
this fire burn and with him like burn up
with it as well
like
the nobody go out and buy know you if
you just meant the person he would have
said he didn't get out he's saying
nobody got out because what the Kovacs
didn't get out he there
it's just I'm like I'm getting goose
bumps talking about it like he knows
that while the Kovacs died that day as
well but I mean any semblance of
humanity really as he goes further in
the soliloquy looked at the sky through
smoke heavy with human fat and God was
not there the cold suffering dark goes
on throw from we are alone live our
lives lacking anything bare to do devise
reason later born from oblivion bear
children hell bound as ourselves go into
oblivion there is nothing else yes I
tried just creative and just crazy and
amazing I mean just just absolutely
questioning the essence of existence
which is I mean something you know maybe
is done a lot in soubiros today but
again it's just so awesome but this was
like what 87 and it's just amazingly
good safe I ever think that's no
five-act even better even better yeah
probably written in 84 and quite nice to
see the therapist at dinner I like the
way they're spread on the table with the
two of her friends the sort of academic
friends and it's kind of almost like a
Roy no I brought blink test but it's got
a nice symmetrical pattern to it and you
know the idea that he would just spill
the beans on something so horrific is
basically you know the guy wants to know
some quote/unquote kinky stuff that
Rorschach might be in true the famed
vigilante and Malcolm's just honest to
the point of brutality really saying she
was abducted killed butchered and fed to
German shepherds and you know it
horrifies his wife and the guest as well
yeah I love how one of the guests is
just like oh boy was she tied and gagged
up and helpless but it's sort of ties
back to this idea of the comic superhero
like in you know previous to this like
it was the damsel in distress who got
captured and choose hanging over like a
pool of sharks or something by a rope
and you know the hero
and then the film would be like you'll
never get a hero man right whereas now
like if he showed it would be like hello
hero man I've tied this woman up to a
burning building handcuffed her at give
her ass all she can saw her and off if
she wants to escape hero man you'll
never save her so it's completely
[ __ ] on like this idealistic version
of the superhero and just been like 92
entire um Calgary she phoned Korra her
off and cover Dewey's [ __ ] dogs and
possibly the most one was stirring
closing to an issue is him just holding
the Rorschach blot up to himself self
examining and yeah we zoom in to what
essentially is at the core of any think
if you zoom in deep enough total
blackness yeah he's a darkness absorbed
into it and the final panel symbolically
he's a blank panel of darkness yeah it'd
be nice if they cut to like the dinner
party guests in a taxi like it come dine
with me in the world like I'd give that
dinner party or one out of ten but you
know what more eiders here are some
powers is really good mm-hmm and I mean
that innocence closes the issue you know
we've seen the transformation and I
think pound for pound II is one of the
best Watchmen issues just in of itself
it tells her to a terrific story it's
the best one Tom you know don't want to
hear nothing else and if you disagree
I'll cut your head off
yeah really good it's so many of the
panel's stick in my mind yeah and we'd
never really seen like a comic book
character psychologically deconstructed
in such a manner and and shown like that
they had a horrific childhood like it's
just really breathtaking and um one of
my favorite as well addendums the extra
stuff we get at the end like reports on
Walter from the Charlton home which as
we discussed before Charlton comics
very influential in Watchmen we also get
two really great ones at the end a
letter from the desk of Malcolm Basie
being hopeful
for the future so it's before we meet
him in the in the issue and there what
do you make of his dream age fourteen
that kind of horrific [ __ ] sex
beast yeah so he says that he walks in
and catches his mom having sex but he
doesn't understand what's really going
on he's got like a child drawing of like
two people stuck together and submerged
as one and it's yeah it's just very
messed up you can say like his idea of
sex is very strange
and what I love about this whole thing
is though that previous to this we'd had
Booga extracts and sort of you know like
really nice things about people and
excerpts from chapters and things like
that whereas Rorschach's it's just as
rest sheet yam yeah and it's it's just
like it sums him up perfectly he's not
part of society can't function as a
normal person no and we see in the
Shelton home basically an essay by
himself talk about his parents and he
compares himself to President Truman and
his mother invention and Truman and
Ozymandias are kind of similar in the
sort Adam Bomb kind of aesthetic they're
just quite interesting for them to pull
it in yeah and I think it's made up it's
sort of his mom says I all we got
divorced because we didn't agree
politically oh that's not a reason that
you would split up so she's obviously
just come up with some like crap reason
to tell Rorschach but like a lot of
children who don't know one of their
parents have a really idealistic version
of them and like we've seen it done a
thousand times in fiction when it's like
my admirer daddy was a war hero and he
died saving 45 men on his sinking boat
like that actually was what my dad did I
never I never knew him but like and like
my mom told us that so obviously that
happened but I know a lot of other
people alike my dad was a Navy and they
sort of like have this idealistic
version of their parent so Rorschach
completely runs with this imagination of
like what his dad was like and he wants
to live up to how many likes president
Truman who had like in no I'm not
tolerance but you know didn't compromise
with people and Rorschach takes this and
it sort of informs his personality like
Rorschach doesn't compromise with people
either and in me even goes to the point
of his death and it probably leads back
to this moment of like imagining what
his dad would be like and he hates his
mother so bad that you just imagines his
dad to be this perfect man who who in
rush I even like sympathizers with and
was like well I probably would have run
away if I had to being him as well but
he doesn't take into account that his
dad abandoned him and we get the New
York State psychology hospital West
Branch report which has lots of typos
than if you saw that which is well yeah
it's a really nice time yeah um yeah
brilliant a posting just about yeah yeah
we got a picture of young Walter as well
it's all great stuff you know for the
whole issue really and these documents
are just a fantastic ography of one of
the great characters of graphic know me
you know and and it's got Moloch's
different names in it as well yeah which
to me sort of symbolizes that he's moved
from town to town and every time it
keeps getting talked air caught sorry
like recently we've seen Jon Venables
who was a child murderer who got blown
witness protection he got moved from he
keeps getting moved and he keeps getting
found out and they have to keep changing
his name and giving him a new identity
and it sort of I sort of think Moloch's
life was like that where it was such a
famous felon that he it's impossible for
him to have a normal life and you know
it sums up the same way that Rorschach
it's impossible for him to have a normal
life well I mean that is you know if you
six please get in touch with us watching
The Watchmen pod at gmail.com or comment
below what do you think about the issue
what fear is you have what you enjoy
cetera issue seven actually be really
good as well up over two dragons are
like this one remember Laurie and Dan
it's bases their relationship it's
another kind of worn header you know
yeah
so bill it's the story stand alone and
but they also build to the overall
narrative in a really subtle way and so
yeah looking forward to that one it
probably won't be better than this this
issue but you know I say that every week
right well even though we'd only do it
once a month a ring Tom every weekend go
it probably won't be as good so we'll
get into some quick emails at the end so
remember please email in again watching
watch from Cod at gmail.com our first
one comes from Hawkeye says hey guys
know the actual Hawkeye from Avengers I
don't know how you doing mate I just was
watching one of your movies you know it
was great wait he's all gonna get his
own movie eventually juvie probably not
no no its new a character you'd have to
be a bit of a [ __ ] and named you
YouTube channel after them right hey
guys thanks for emailing in or guy hey
guys this progress so far
you both have some great skill in
discerning the themes and style of
Watchmen and it's great great fun to
hear you talk about issues I'm a
transgender woman and Watchmen does not
seem to be very popular very popular
among the LGBTQ reading comic readership
literally the only discussion I've had
about Watchmen of him we've heterosexual
funds of a novel I was curious whether
you two had any guesses as to why
Watchmen might be less popular among
queer readers looking forward to hearing
more from you guys and looking forward
to Doomsday Clock despite myself Alice
so death any opinions on this well I
feel a bit bad now for slugging that was
a really nice email and yeah it's kind
of I'd never actually considered that to
be honest
mm-hm I really don't know why it would
be less popular because there are quite
a lot of gay and lesbian character well
no massive a mumbles yeah yeah and
they're not depicted in a negative light
either and which especially do you know
during at the time of the AES obviously
that AIDS crisis was very high and to be
gay sort of a lot of people were just
homophobic because they thought like oh
if I go within 500 feet of a gay person
I'll catch HIV or something and so it is
fair
strange well it's very unique that
Watchmen it doesn't take that stance it
depicts its gay characters in a very you
know good light like some I'm sure read
somewhere that was Amanda's might even
be gay
I am silhouette so well
yes illa what and do you know these are
brilliant characters that they're not
like painted out as a week or anything
so yeah there's quite strange that you
know people don't read it that much yeah
I hadn't really considered it too much
myself that too busy reading Hawkeye
that's why Tom it's popular it's a
popular in Europe a lot of people like
does he have his own comic book like he
does has he done anything of himself
he's just a sort of a bit part guy no
actually I never really liked the Marvel
movies you know I used to be like
slugging them off talking about DC
anyway I've seen a big sale for all of
the the Marvel blu-ray films and I'd
never seen like the Thor movies or
anything so I thought I'll just buy the
box set anyway watch them all back to
back they're [ __ ] incredible Tom I've
been living a lie and absolutely
brilliant so yeah if you're a DC hey if
you're a Marvel hater like me actually
check out all of the Marvel movies in
chronological order you'll buddy love
them and Hawkeye is great in them mm-hmm
is it wrong I think the Marvel movies a
trash I don't think what I did Tom
though I did I feel like 25 years
um I know they've only been out since
2000 and pay or whatever but you know
but yeah just you know pick pick up Iron
Man Tom and go from there I've never
seen Thor one and Thor - so I thought so
I thought I know I'll get the box there
cuz I'm not seeing them and I quite
enjoyed door Ragnarok give them or watch
Tom cuz they do so much we're very
little late it sort of works as a TV
show they all kind of tie into one
another and and it's just really nice
character building but you don't need
like any superhero movies do you no no I
don't really but III appreciate what
they are and make seeing Star Wars today
so I seen it last night
loved it first 45 minutes Tom
did you like the force awakens I didn't
mind it yeah yeah well the first 45
minutes [ __ ] for this film [ __ ] hell
mate I was literally like Jesus Christ
this is terrible and then from there it
gets absolutely incredible like are you
big star Wars fan it's Star Wars for me
has always been
I love the design in the law but I've
always found the stories a little bit
lackluster okay so it's a bit strange
that you you do a podcast but you know
I'm massive Star Wars fan but anyway
yeah so you you probably will still
enjoy it but you know just sit tight for
them first 45 minutes that's all I'll
say okay okay and just just quickly as
well to follow-up analysis emailed a
little bit of research and I discovered
this thing called a coltd Watchmen the
true fate of hoodie just isn't captain
metropolis it was a paper by James
Gifford originally published in 1999 and
he's basically got a theory that hoodie
justice and captain metropolis did not
die as alluded to in supplementary
material presidented of watchmen but are
alive and well in 1985 and you can see
this basically the first issue you can
see them aspecting hands apparently and
I won't think into it too much but if
you do a bit of googling listeners you
can find it's really interesting there's
a great article on it and basically they
showed it to Dave Gibbons and he replied
the quote that wasn't our intention but
it's such an interesting implausible
fear that I'm reluctant to deny it and
yeah to do it yeah that's what I meant
all along apparently it was disproven in
before Watchmen as hoodie good as he
showed is being killed by night owl but
[ __ ] before Watchmen yeah not read it
but [ __ ] will have to do a series on
it soon but really absently by not
reluctantly for me because I've already
spent about 40 quid I get your money's
worth I guess yeah yes I chose me
patreon his role in it holy [ __ ] too
busy to Jersey no donors so far but you
know raise the queue you know I'm a bit
annoyed patreon servers must be downer
so patron please people yeah because I
did actually I don't know if you've been
listening to this podcast but I've
actually bought a new microphone
yeah and the sound should sound a lot
better set me back a bit so you know get
to the [ __ ] patreon now like they said
that's the only reason I do the podcast
scenes for the patreon so you know if it
wasn't for that I don't know why I do so
shouts who a deaf space Ron she had to
David as well who got in touch he says
dear Tom and deaf I was led to your show
courtesy the real fans of real comic
book Facebook group Chad to that group
by the way I became a fan and a few
people had shared our episode I'm saying
to listen to us that was really cool
I won't go through most of David's email
it was a great email just basically goes
through the issues were discussed prior
and just things he's noticed there as
well and he was also talking about um
you know lost girls remember we
mentioned lost girls yeah Alan Moore's
Law School's which I own but never read
yeah I'm sort of flicked for he says
I've actually flipped through most of
lost girls I don't think there's
anything Peter philic per se maybe Eber
philic or epiphytic which is one adult
on one underage with post PBT child
especially in a story of in a story
tangent drawn in the old school
lithograph and it was about incest when
a family of four one door and one son so
it's clearly quite diverse well I'm
gonna be rushing as soon as Tom over
thing I hear me man falling for me tea
I've got it I've got to leave I love the
show can't wait for the rest sincerely
David thank you so much David
he also says PS before you should
conclude the show could you please make
some kind of summary analysis for the
two main publications in the watchman
universe being Nova Express in the new
frontiersman like what kind of politics
they seem to support left-wing or
right-wing more libertarian all for it
and that kind of thing so yeah that
could be quite cool to do death yeah
well we're definitely gonna be doing
more than Watchmen we're gonna do before
watch them and at some point and then
you know I think me and Tom we've sort
of talked about expanding this into more
of a comic podcast so here keep an eye
out will be will be doing more than
simply Watchmen stuff I don't know would
be got a shitload more work because
doomsday clocks gonna be done with you
fine
stavropoulos and I think that comes out
at the 27th December or something so
probably doing episode was really on
there yeah I'm excited I'm excited for
that and so Christmas for it yeah that's
it just thought just maybe an hour or so
graphic novel chat just cancel the whole
thing
sit around listen wait little red thing
there download in Eric Ferguson is our
final emails is Halak he's back you know
I just wanna show Eric because he's
dedicated
and he always pops up the other week he
sent me a picture of some Watchmen toys
and he seemed he must have seemed
somewhere and they were absolutely
hilarious so yeah just want to thank
Eric for continuing to support the show
he always provides great insight read
his email what do you mean this email is
only two words long it's [ __ ] off he
says hello again many thanks reading my
entire letter on your podcast I should
have snuck in a well-placed advert for
my day job and also thanks again for
requesting my opinion on the tales of
the black freighter when I first read
the comic I was 15 years old and I
really liked it Eva intended to skip it
over 30 years of reading it the story
has grown on me we talked about Final
Fantasy 14 or something
and they were like look at the first 40
hours of it it's not very good but once
you get past those first 40 hours it
becomes amazing oh my lining up to play
that he says the story line is one of
the more challenging transitions that
the masked animal makes the difference
in scene and Tony's had brought from the
rest of Watchmen I look at the
Blackfriars the journey and character
development
Ozymandias for the mystery to work we
cannot see all the machinations that our
human dose goes through I think it's a
success by alla more in the short
stories miniseries a limited series is
not always possible for there to be much
character development in the villain by
using the story of in a story more can
give Ozymandias some more development
later on in the series Ozzy reveals how
he journeys and the path Alexander the
Great and here in this issue there is
the caption in tales of the black Freya
east across tonight skies east border
the naked backs of murdered men both men
go east as he personally kills coming
maybe the shark represents the comedian
the other shark circle but eventually
leave soda dr. Manhattan and Nite Owl
and Silk Spectre also leave oz e in his
Carnac at the story's end maybe I'm
making shirt now I mean what do you
think about this comparison death yeah I
have definitely heard that it symbolizes
human Dyess before so yeah I haven't
read it for 30 years or probably can't
see as in-depth as arrogant mm-hmm but
yes shout out and bull shark is a big
biggie rule check refers to he's being
unmasked as his disguise which we said
years later in the film Kill Bill to a
world like to refer to as Tarantino or
seize the matrix one likes to Agent
Smith fights Tarantino cooled this idea
the hero's real the skies into a
monologue aha Clark Kent is the true
disguise from Superman yeah I wonder if
he lifted this from Rorschach he says he
might have yeah it's quite a famous
monologue I don't think it's correct but
yeah he I mean I don't think Tarantino's
monologue is correct which he says that
super on views humans at bumbling idiots
and I think he just puts on his Clark
Kent persona and to kind of disguise
himself even more but yeah I do kind of
think Watchmen is responsible for a lot
more than it gets credited for like Mad
Max we mentioned before you there's I'm
sure you're not locked in here with me
has been used in your you know a couple
of times um I mean I used on my first
day at school I think I did that job
earlier in the podcast and was not funny
then either but yet it is yeah and I
guess finally you know Eric great email
thank you again he talks like the motion
comic and have we watched it what do we
think about it
yeah tried watching it and but one guy
does all the voices as yet and when he
does Laurie's it just I just think oh
[ __ ] hell I could just tell this as a
guy putting on a woman's voice and it's
up yeah puts me off like I don't know
why they just got one guy to do every
single voice
mm yeah it's odd but I mean still
I think animation wise is pretty
impressive and so I sort of watch a
little bit before we go on air just to
kind of you know revisit scenes but yeah
so next we will be back for doomsday
issue two and then obviously I think
we'll get to issue seven you know in the
near future so thank you to everyone for
listening the download numbers are
growing which is awesome to see we're
going to consist of base now so please
tell your friends if you know they like
Watchmen or graphic novels if they want
to listen you know give them a didn't we
didn't tell them about the mid-season
break Tom right okay so we're not doing
issue 7 next time
the lads just lied to you so I
understand if you didn't subscribe we're
actually doing a midseason break where
we're gonna talk about Alan Moore's
Batman The Killing Joke cool and so
definitely check out that episode it's
gonna be gonna be as good as these ones
potentially maybe even better so check
it out subscribe tell your mate or
subscribe you know going to school
tomorrow and go are you subscribe a
decade or I'll knock you out the old
desk page room yeah don't let it slowly
go there it's barren land it's pretty
much just a blank website with an 8 a
profile picture ain't nothing better
than that email in your inbox this
person's a patreon now is Wow
come on well all the hard work yeah
thank you everyone look forward to
getting that email this month thank you
everyone for listening thank you to Alan
and Dave and everyone involved in
watchmen for creating you know
absolutely masterpiece it's a joy to
talk about let us know your thoughts on
this issue or the show in general
watching what's to impart at gmail.com
or comment below cause we always get to
the comments always get to the
correspondents death your website that
sort of stuff
yeah definition core at UK I've just
done a big redesign on it so make sure
you go and check it out I've started
doing video essays in which I talked
about The Walking Dead why the Marvel
movies are so good and I'm also doing
one about the last Jedi today so make
sure you check it
all right all right yes so if you
enjoyed this I doing a few of a podcast
alphabet allaka which is kind of an A to
Z journey for the history of Metallica
which one of my favorite bands also
battle a resume in which me and death
the many episodes of that which is where
I just talk about battle rap with battle
rappers yeah if you like Tom Waits as
well they soon old Tom Waits bug gets
cooled down and all check that out but
yeah this is always a joy to do deaf
thanks again bro yeah thanks a lot
Tom over to you Tom back in the studio
you